[Music]
what'd you think of Mandy I loved it
yeah the very first thought I was kind
of confused and I remember I think I saw
it four times in theaters when I lived
in New York loved it I don't know why I
just have the obsession of like needing
to re-watch things and like look at
things from a new view like as I've
gotten older Roseanne has only gotten
better got it which is like a dumb
comparison to the famous cosmoto's Mandy
thing but like it's just like the way
you perceive Andy and Roseanne are like
on the same it's kind of weird yeah
Roseanne's much more High art but the uh
yeah uh no I like it's just it's
interesting because I feel like every
month every year that you [ __ ] live
you perceive things differently so I
just I re-watch [ __ ] so so much not
after your brain is crystallized it's
getting the [ __ ] place man I'm
telling you it's it's for real yeah it's
crazy in your 30s
I forgot I mean like there's like a I
think I've had somewhere like 35 hmm
your brain starts to like have that
crystallization of like um you like the
craps that you have curated through this
time of your life have solidified and
you were like
that that's going to be the thing that
you can like teach people and you become
more of a teacher so there's not much
time left so I have to I have to get
this special out because it's the last
chance I have for a unique brain and I'm
sure that like there's like obviously
like I don't know there's exceptions to
the rule but definitely anticipate me in
30. I mean if you look at any anything
though like I mean like there's still
great people that do great things but
the things that are pivotal that you
remember are the things that whenever
they were younger yeah yeah 100 which is
fine you're human what the [ __ ] you
can't stay on top forever you can't be
this like [ __ ] innovative person I
think guys like social media person
people I think that you develop a very
narcissistic mindset to think that like
anything you do is relevant to yeah you
put out there yeah when it's not like
it's just like there's gonna be a day
where people just do not give a [ __ ]
about you and I think that's just like
something that like you have to accept
in any facet except Mr Beast everyone
and must know and needs to know what
Jimmy is doing there's going to be
somebody who comes along that's like
younger who does something there where
they're just like
it's not going to be instantaneous but I
do think there will be like a new Mr
Beast yeah but the thing too is like
when the new Mr Beast comes along
there's gonna be I think like a small
group of them and I think like that's
gonna it's gonna be like a multi like a
multiplier like I think like when the
new Mr Beast comes along it's gonna be
like a success and a growth but it's
going to be like a group of people or
whatever I don't know if they'll be
friends or not I just expect that like
it's not just going to be a singular end
today anymore because like back in the
day it was like a PewDiePie but then
PewDiePie bread like jacksepticeye
Markiplier all these kind of people and
then from there like you look at the
commentary community of like Ethan Klein
and then it was like all these [ __ ]
people now like all these other people
all these [ __ ] people know well yeah
I mean like even you guys or whatever
like being able to find that niche in
there but like I think in terms of like
this like success and like you see
people that are like emulating this Mr B
style where they like they yell every
single thing they say and like text on
screen or whatever big energy yeah and
that's like obviously this is them just
mimicking him but I think when something
new comes along and it's like this new
breath of fresh air of like how are they
doing this or like this kind of like
bigger than life thing it will happen
because people have grown up watching
him yeah but I think that when it
happens it's going to be more normalized
and like yeah it just it's it's with
everything it's just like people see
things they take from it they evolve it
or whatever I I sort of feel like that's
happening on Twitch a little bit like
with Kai and I show speed I mean those
guys their growth has been [ __ ]
insane yeah so crazy I mean why does
that happen it's disgusting to see I
honestly like well I'm glad this is the
private episode because I just like the
majority of like the the fandoms around
twitch and stuff it's so [ __ ] like
parasitic and it's like so like I don't
know it's just something where it's like
people are being rewarded for nothing in
a way I I want to differentiate Kai
though because I feel like Kai apart
from like just being a streamer I feel
like he's actually he wants to make
music and he does make music and I do
think it's cool that he's like
leveraging what he he has into like a
craft like he's you can leverage
whatever the [ __ ] you want what I'm
saying is like the majority of the
success though comes from people's
perceptions of like
weird parasocial relationships online
between streamer and this yeah and like
the kind of like Dynamics they have for
literally nothing in return yeah and
that isn't to say that like I mean I
don't know I'm not that kind of person
to be like what they're doing is
worthless but at the end of the day it's
like I just don't like the thing of like
people's the entire system is based
around like people's obsession with you
sure or something yeah yeah that's fair
so I don't know there's it that kind of
these people are obsessed with them yeah
yeah I would say that's a pro but I
think a lot of people that like take
time to to actively put a chat into a
wall of something that will never be
seen is [ __ ] psychotic
and it's like a rational and it's like
weird because the thing is like people
wanting to get your attention and stuff
and it's like yeah and people throwing
money at you yeah like literally
donating haha that was so funny and
they're just like and they don't even
acknowledge it yeah and they don't care
it's so odd I'm just like it's so
[ __ ] strange yeah and I show speed
he's so young and like he has this kind
of attention and stuff like that too and
it's like I feel like with speed with
speed to me just as and you know any
speed fan probably call me a boomer for
this but I feel like from a distance
speed was willing to do whatever to like
be funny and I feel like he's not the
first person to do this but I feel with
twitch especially there are people that
have like gone in that weird territory
where it's almost like they're it's like
almost like humiliation tactics to like
garnish your attention so it's like
don't if you donate money and you kind
of like encourage the stream I will do
something that's either like very
bizarre or [ __ ] like personally
embarrassing yeah I don't ever think
it's malicious like no no no I'm not
coming out it from a place where like I
think that they're actively knowing that
like what they're doing but I just think
it's like it's with anything that's like
new and cool I just don't think that
that thing has longevity I guess is the
big thing I would have thought with
Aiden
like he would have got out of there
after the whole gambling thing but like
he's fine I think Wayne got out of there
just like I I kind of thought maybe
there's like a couple year period here
where it's like young teenage hypebeasts
like really relate to him then they grow
up a few years later and they're like oh
yeah I used to watch Aiden and then like
their attention for him just kind of
yeah the thing about Aiden though from
what I've seen of streams and I did I I
included him in that Andrew Tate video
with like Nico and stuff and it was
because he's very like I don't know from
what I've seen a lot of his streams is
he just like piggybacks
a lot of people yeah and stuff and he
like just kind of like forcibly includes
himself into these things yeah and stuff
because he has the clout too or whatever
and then those people become bigger than
him but then it's still just like one of
these things where he just like has that
past experience so he's able to just
kind of like force his way into things
while doing like nothing yeah while
doing nothing yeah at the end of the day
streaming for the most part I mean it's
not for the most part it is entirely
about like who you are as a person it's
not sure but I think there's a lot of
streamers like germa I think is somebody
who has like a like a really great
personality very funny and witty and
stuff and they do things and like I'm
not going to be a person who's sitting
there and being like Oh streaming is
just like watching people no but it's a
performance in live time but I think
there is like it's inherently like a
parasocial relationship in real time
with your fans and that's just like
inevitable because there's like
YouTubers who have that like I look at
Markiplier fans and I'm like you like
did you I love that [ __ ] that video
oh my God it's so funny the Markiplier
video of the kid like hugging him in the
mall and he's like rubbing his face on
him and stuff have you seen that no no
it's so funny or whatever
[ __ ] he's like okay thanks this dad's
trying to pull away
[Music]
[Laughter]
dog trying to rub his scent on the couch
this whole thing of like it's the whole
thing of like it's it's whenever like
people
um like if you say if if you say a joke
that's very offensive at a place where
you're very high you're just like well
it's just a joke but it's like you have
to put yourself in a place of like you
do have like some kind of power you have
to have like the responsibility to
realize what is right and wrong yeah and
like though things are inevitable you
have to you have to like be the leading
voice of being like vocal about things
or whatever which I don't I don't know
what the [ __ ] I'm getting at I'm just
saying like
death toll streamers
[Laughter]
no I don't know